hey guys if you haven't been playing
along on twitter or facebook i am
actually in israel right now i'm on the
beach
in tel aviv this is the mediterranean
sea behind me it's about 6 30 a.m on uh
thursday november
december 3rd um
there was this mass shooting in san
bernardino california last night which
i've been trying to stay off social
media a little bit while i've been here
uh and focus i was doing a video
conference i gave a speech at a video
conference thing and i've been i've been
trying to meet with people and talk
about peace i'm gonna do an interview
today that i think you guys are gonna
find really interesting anyway i saw
this thing last night and then basically
just couldn't sleep all night so it's
super early here and i just wanted to
make a video on this thing real quick
um
yeah this is this is terrible i i can't
tell you how bizarre it feels to be
halfway across the world uh especially
here in israel where they deal with this
kind of thing all the time at different
levels uh and that it's that there was a
massive
shooting uh not that far away from los
angeles where i live
um i thought the reaction of course
uh on social media was
all the usual nonsense you know what i
mean there was almost this like glee at
the beginning
from uh the usual suspects when they
thought it was gonna be a white guy that
did it or white people that did it or
christian terrorists and people were
blaming the republicans and the
nra and all that and of course i never
defend the republicans or the nra and
then slowly it came out it sounds like
uh this guy has
that he might be pakistani or something
i don't know
or now his father i guess is saying that
he is a religious muslim i don't it's
early in all this
um
but i i guess i wanted to make a video
just to say something which is
uh we gotta be unafraid
to call out evil [ __ ] no matter which
quarter it comes from so whether this
guy had been a christian fundamentalist
or a muslim fundamentalist or a jewish
fundamentalist or a scientologist
fundamentalist or [ __ ]
you know
star wars fundamentalist
well that guy would have been pretty
good but the point is we have to not be
afraid to call this [ __ ] out you cannot
there is no excuse you cannot kill
innocent people no matter what your
problem is no matter how begrudged you
feel no matter how whatever you think
has been done to you the second we allow
that the second we excuse it
if all bets are off then anyone can do
anything for any reason
that's it it really is that simple uh if
we want society if we want this world
that's getting smaller because of
technology like this if we want this
world
to be better then that [ __ ] cannot
happen and that does not excuse state
violence either i don't know how many
times i have to say it
for these regressive morons
uh anyway um it's weird we're in a small
world these days
and uh we'll find out more
and and we'll see what happens but i'll
be here for a couple more days so uh
keep playing along on social media and
you can find out what i'm up to and as
always i thank you guys for your support
and digging what i do